the senate is soon going to vote on the
confirmation of joe biden's supreme
court pick catanji brown jackson now she
will be confirmed and it will be an
accomplishment for joe biden
rightfully so donald trump had as an
accomplishment i mean he picked horrible
people but he had as an accomplishment
not only getting a bunch of judges
confirmed to lower courts as has joe
biden but trump also had three supreme
court justices to his name and they are
accomplishments i mean let's be honest
they are disastrous justices who have
pulled the supreme court more to the
right than it's been in a very long time
but if you're a right-wing nut
you like it and you see it as an
accomplishment so when not if when
judge jackson is confirmed to the
supreme court
it will be an accomplishment for
president joe biden and maybe he will
get more opportunities but we are now
starting to hear from republicans about
whether they will support the
confirmation now you know and i know and
anybody who takes the time to look
knows
that
judge jackson
is as qualified as any of the nine
justices currently on the court with a
wider breadth of experience than any
justice on the court the closest is
stephen breyer who she would be
replacing but
it still appears many republicans maybe
even most are going to be voting no we
don't yet know whether mitt romney will
vote to confirm judge jackson susan
collins republican from maine has said
she will vote to confirm judge jackson
and her explanation is so simple it's
she has the experience and she has the
qualifications that's it
and it really should be that simple but
i'm going to give you an example of the
worst of the worst here's a clip of
republican senator roy blunt
this is almost beyond parody
he was interviewed by george
stephanopoulos on abc yesterday and he
says
that jackson should be confirmed
and it will be a great accomplishment
that she will be confirmed it will be a
high point for the country but he's not
going to support that confirmation and
when george stephanopoulos asks well why
he delivers an unintelligible word salad
reminiscent of sarah palin who by the
way we'll talk about a little bit later
today listen to this english judge
katanji brown uh jackson have you made
up your mind yet
well i have george and
good to be with you this morning you
know i've thought
initially
my sense is that the president certainly
had every uh good intention and every
every right in the campaign to talk
about putting
the first black woman on the court i
think it's time for that to happen
i was hoping that i could be part of
that i had a great conversation with her
really there are two criterias i said
immediately one is
is the person qualified for the job and
two is what's their judicial philosophy
okay she's certainly qualified i think
he's got a great personality i think
will be a good colleague on the court
but the judicial philosophy it seems to
be
not the philosophy of looking at what
the law says and the constitution says
and applying that
but going through some method that
allows you to try to
look at the constitution as a more
flexible document
now i wish that were true
it's not true
and it was actually surprising to many
progressives
how centrist
on the questions of judicial philosophy
and uh
seeing the constitution more as a sacred
text versus a living document how how
centrist her answers were
this is just not true what roy blunt is
saying
in the law and there are cases that show
that that's
her view i think she's certainly going
to be confirmed i think it will be a
high point for the country to see her go
on the court and take
her unique perspective to the court but
i don't think she's the kind of judge
that will
really do the kind of work that i think
needs to be done by what on earth is he
talking about he likes the fact that
there's going to be the first black
woman on the court he says that her
qualifications are without question but
he's not big on her judicial philosophy
which he claims without evidence nor
citing a single example that she's not
strict enough about her interpretation
of the constitution but there's no
substance there it sounds like basically
the only things he's defending are
reasons to vote for her confirmation the
court and
i won't be supporting her but i'll i'll
be joining others and understanding the
importance of
this moment
if it's a high point for the country why
not support her right
well i think the lifetime appointments
have a different criteria than other
appointments i've supported a
significant number of president biden's
nominees to to offices that will
end their time will end while he's still
in office or when he leaves office i
think that's a different criteria than
somebody putting somebody on the court
for life
uh i don't think i've seen but you're
still not really giving an example of
what it is about her answers that
concerned you so this is mealy mouth to
say the least and quite frankly it might
be just as simple as i'm not going to
vote for her because my supporters will
be mad and i don't want to anger my
supporters a lot of the republicans who
are saying they're not going to vote for
her don't even really seem to know why
they're not going to vote for her they
they seem to sometimes rattle off
something about
sentencing for people in possession of
explicit child sexual images but even
then it's not even really clear what
they thought the sentences should be in
certain cases it's all very weird and
there's a report from business insider
which uh indicates that mitch mcconnell
the republican senate minority leader
has been
pushing other republican senators to
also not support judge jackson so we
will wait and see
she's going to be confirmed by
absolutely every indication the question
is how many republicans are actually
going to support her and on
qualifications
there is nothing there in terms of a
valid reason not to support her uh we
have this is a disturbing story i want
to uh uh let everybody know in advance
that this is a very very disturbing
story that we're about to talk about um
an anti-abortion nut in her late 20s has
been caught by police
this is really tough
with five fetuses in her house
um
this is a real headline i was convinced
when i first saw it this this must be
bogus this can't possibly be real
but it is all too real and it is
horrifying
and um
this seems like a very very sick person
dc police find five fetuses in the home
of anti-abortion activist lauren handy
people will freak out when they hear the
anti-abortion activists reportedly said
washington dc police found five fetuses
in the home of an anti-abortion activist
on wednesday lauren handy sat outside
her home as officers
brought out coolers containing fetuses
handy declined to tell a reporter
outside her home what was there but said
people will freak out when they hear
metro police confirmed to huffpost that
it found the five fetuses after being
sent to investigate a tip so that means
someone knew how sick this woman was
and they reported her which is good it's
a good thing that someone reported this
woman
the police statement says upon further
investigation mpd located five fetuses
inside a residence at the location the
fetuses were collected by the dc office
of the chief medical examiner
um
image of the woman sitting outside her
home has been published widely to
twitter
another article on this from nbc
washington
lauren handy is one of nine people
accused of blocking access to a dc
abortion clinic in 2020. so this is
already someone on the radar of police
for her uh i i i don't even to even call
it anti-abortion activism seems not to
actually take into consideration what it
is that these people do
um police went to 28 year old lauren
handy's basement apartment
and uh investigating a tip about a
possible biohazard material in her house
they collected fetuses it it's just sick
i'm not even gonna doubt can you guys
get it okay you guys if this is
difficult to wrap one's head around did
anyone know
how long did she have them what was she
going to use these fetuses for and
understand one really important thing
here okay
i am guessing if you asked her or other
anti-abortion activists willing to do
this why they did it
they would say it's to prove some kind
of point for the shock value in some
kind of anti-abortion propaganda to
expose the evils of of stem cell
research embryonics i don't know what
they would say but they would have some
justification but understand that by
their own logic these are people they
believe
that these are people
some of them believe at conception some
of them believe it five weeks some of
them believe okay
if you believe that a fetus is a person
you've basically stolen human bodies
from a morgue which is criminal
understand that this is by their logic
and their framework of what they believe
about this issue these are fully human
lives according to them
so this would be like keeping five
dead bodies that again by their that
have been killed by their logic
um these are some
you know
i don't know
are these bates motel twists or
i don't know
um but this is absolutely sick this is
so ba you know the it's sort of like the
fox hosts who argue that they give you
the news and the truth on air then they
get sued for what they say and in court
they go
we're entertainers we're just
entertainers that's it this isn't news
when they get sued is it going to be an
example of the same thing well listen
these are these are humans murderer oh
but you just got caught with five
fetuses these are humans right so this
it's like having five bodies from a
morgue no no no this is just this is
tissue
that's all it is these people are sick
these people are sick and i'm i'm not
using the t word right what we often
call the domestic you know what we call
them i'm not using it because i just
don't know that it's legally appropriate
but it's pretty damn close it's pretty
damn close what these people do
uh to shift gears and it's very hard to
shift gears from this
i want to invite all of you to uh
participate in our next town hall we are
doing a town hall opening the phone
lines to all of our viewers viewers and
listeners it'll be tuesday april 19th at
6 pm eastern it'll be live on our pacman
live channel uh really looking forward
to it really looking forward to hearing
from you guys and i'll i'll have more
reminders coming up let me know your
thoughts about these first couple of
stories find me on twitter deepakman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
the david pakman show is made possible
by our viewers
it is the most important
revenue source that we have when people
sign up at joinpackman.com you can now
gift memberships to other people
but we just have too much to talk about
for me to spend too much time on that so
i will just say sign up at
joinpackman.com we would love to have
you
the
weekend that we just had
trying to figure out the right words
it's not funny anymore guys if it ever
was and it was never funny to many of us
if it ever was this trump cult
is not funny anymore they are motivated
tens of millions of them still want
trump again
they are willing to travel
they are willing to pay just to hear
from the guy
he is increasingly the dangerous cult
leader
they are increasingly the dangerous
cultists i just finished reading jeff
gwyn's great book about charles manson
and when i read about the followers of
manson and what they were willing to do
in their case they were willing to kill
it's hard not to think about trump
cultists and the danger of this group of
people
cannot be overstated there was a rally
in michigan over the weekend we're going
to look at what trump said we're going
to look at what the speaker said we're
going to look at what the attendees said
and one of the things that is concerning
is
the trumpists who now come across my
streams of these events they are angrier
than ever they used to ignore my
coverage of these rallies before now
dozens and dozens of them will email me
furious maybe it's because they are
angry that he lost and he's no longer
president maybe it's because they are
emboldened maybe it's because they don't
like that trump is making no sense
whatsoever at these rallies but
for whatever reason they are very very
triggered by our coverage of these
rallies let's start with the things that
donald trump said yesterday it was a
very glitchy night there were like five
or six of those weird glitch twitch
issues
i'm not gonna play all of them here's
one where i guess he was trying to talk
about zuckerberg drop boxes and he just
glitched and it was very strange the
elimination of zuckerberg dropbox i call
them the
unlock boxes and it's always that
shoulder glitch right when he makes a
mistake it's not clear what it is we
don't know is it neurological is it
psychological we don't know there were
half a dozen of them yesterday i won't
bore you with more of them we're used to
it up at this uh up until this point in
time
i made a good faith effort to find
anything that trump said that was true
and here's the best i came up with trump
said at one point during the rally
in russia there is such a rigged press
that some russians don't even really
understand
the nature of the war that is going on
that was true
everything else he said was false you
know
they say that
in russia
the people in russia don't even know
they're having a war
because they have a rigged press we have
the same rig press maybe not quite as
severe but it'll be there in the not too
distant future now of course that last
part isn't true although trump would
love to have a rigged press that only uh
uh praises him but that is not true
as crazy as this is going to sound
donald trump floated the idea of going
back to afghanistan he said what we
might go back and the crowd cheered guys
i can't do it i can't do it it was years
of saying he would get us out and he
failed to do it
and then biden got us out and now trump
is so upset with how biden got us out
that he says maybe we'll go back and get
our stuff
and the crowd cheers understand we're
talking about in order to do that you've
got to send troops back in and the crowd
cheers it it's beyond belief you have
many citizens
that the taliban is holding they didn't
get enough with the 85 billion dollars
maybe you ought to go in and take it
back
dumbest thing i've ever seen go back in
finest military equipment in the world
they have them from the goggles to the
700 000 machine guns
it it it is it is incredible
i'm not aware of trump ever having
mentioned joe biden's white house press
secretary jenn saki before
but he did at the saturday rally
and he referred to her
as the woman with the really beautiful
red hair just every there can he can't
talk about anything in a normal way here
is trump on gensake
and
then the woman with this really
beautiful red hair
she left
and she was hit so hard by the military
because they knew i was right the
military understood i was right you know
she's going to msdnc you know that
right
it does appear that it does appear that
jen saki is going to be when she leaves
going to msnbc that act so i guess trump
told two truths in his nearly two hour
speech
they need a redhead they don't have a
redhead over there so they need a red
very slurry as you can imagine and the
crowd just absolutely loving all of it
here is another lie that trump continues
to tell trump once again claiming that
he was the recipient of an award that
does not exist they get worse
and then i was named a long time ago i
was named did you know this a long time
i don't know your chamber of commerce
somebody who the hell knows what it is
they named me the man of the year in
michigan
and i got up
and i said they're stealing your car
business
and i was really rebuked they said that
wasn't a very nice thing to say i said
but now two things one i don't know why
trump was so sweaty throughout the
entire event many of our viewers were
asking that on saturday night but that
award doesn't exist the crowd cheers
anyway it doesn't matter whether you
know if you go this this is the sick
reality guys this trump's been claiming
he got this award man michigan man of
the year for for a very long time
there's no evidence that it exists so
it's been researched by multiple media
outlets they tried since 2016 media
outlets have been trying to verify that
trump got this award there's no evidence
he got it there's no evidence the award
exists
if you go to a trumpist and say you know
that award doesn't exist
he'll that they would come up with
something like
well he should have gotten that award
that award should exist it should be
created it should be given to donald
trump this is how delusional these
cultists are now at another point in the
rally
trump made a completely unintelligible
rant
about we figured out later he's talking
about jeff fortenbury fortenberry who
was convicted of lying to the fbi and
concealing information criminal okay and
trump seemed to sort of be making light
of what happened to jeff fortenberry but
it like didn't make any sense listen to
this million dollars you know
in a great state nebraska
a congressman
is being put in jail over a few dollars
that he possibly didn't even know
anything about he's going to jail a few
thousand dollars
and yet
this guy gives
417 million dollars to all these states
the money it's passed around like uh
like pizza like pizza at a party and
nothing happens to him they're putting
this congressman i don't know him well
but he's a congressman and it was over a
very small amount of money
they're going to put him in jail
over a number of thousands like thousand
dollars
that's the it first was like no money
and then it was thousands and then then
it's twenty thousands jeff fortenberry
was convicted of lying to the fbi like
many trump associates have done
concealing information in an
investigation about illegal
contributions made by a foreign national
to his re-election campaign does that
ring a bell to anybody sounds very
similar to some of the investigations
into the people around trump trump then
had a sort of dog whistle attack
on primarily but not exclusively black
athletes who have knelt during the
national or is it knelt or kneeled
during the national anthem saying you
only kneel
um uh you you don't kneel or wait listen
and americans kneel to god and god alone
okay there we go
okay so you guys get the implication you
don't kneel during the anthem you only
kneel to god my senses trump's never
been on his knees for jesus in his life
that's my sense of the guy and then
lastly trump starts to do sort of like a
impression of how he would do a
concession speech
but then he stops for fear that the
media will edit it in an unfair way
be a lot easier for me to do like many
people have done get up and just say
congratulations uh
whoever it is i'm running against i mean
if you're running i'd say
congratulations joe
now watch if i say it i don't want to
say it because they'll put it on like
this is what they do whoa remember the
russia if you're listening thing so they
cut it off immediately because it was a
joke russia if you're listening to do
this or that with her emails or whatever
the hell it was
they admit and then i laughed they left
the whole place was left but they cut it
off immediately i said russia if you're
listening cut nobody cut it off there
that is a lie nobody cut it off there so
this is the dangerous cultist
he has followers he has influence
they're not going away
let's now look at some of the other
people who spoke at the rally
uh donald trump does a rally in michigan
over the weekend it's
outrageous trump lies uncontrollably
next let's go to the other people on the
stage with him they did an opening
prayer
which started with the belief that
donald trump is the current president
they are it it's what's fascinating is
it's almost a religious belief at this
point together so we pray father in
heaven we firmly believe that donald j
trump is the current and true president
of the united states you have raised him
up for this season of time to be used to
be part in saving a nation bless and
protect him and his family from any
physical spiritual attacks and may his
voice stir the people to righteous
action to bring godly men and women into
elected office
this is a really really sick country
guys we've got real problems here we
have real problems and
it is almost a religious belief i mean
it wouldn't shock me if soon they say
actually you know
this is no longer a political belief our
belief that trump is currently the
president
god told us it's now a sincerely held
religious belief we want religious
non-discrimination protection i
shouldn't give them any ideas but this
country's in real trouble we also heard
at this event from republican
congresswoman lisa mclean
who wildly claimed that unemployment is
now at a 40-year high that's not true
trouble we went from an economy that was
booming
to a shambles what we have now is a
shambles it's a complete mess
unemployment
40-year high
labor shortage we can't find goods at
the store now that is completely untrue
as many of you know unemployment is
incredibly low it's at 3.6 percent we're
putting a historical chart of the
unemployment rate up on the screen and
as you can see it is very
very very low
um then lisa mclean went on to say trump
got osama bin laden now some of you guys
might remember barack obama walking out
and saying
we got osama bin laden it was barack
obama who got osama bin laden you could
say it was against the law to go in you
could say anything you want
but it wasn't trump but that's what lisa
says well president trump was in office
we didn't have a war
and i think he made three peace treaties
peace
caught osama osama bin laden
and solimani
al-baghdadi
and this president is weak right not
true it was barack obama who got osama
bin laden last clip of lisa mclean lisa
mclean says
migrants crossing the border are
basically all criminals rapists etc kind
of rehashing a trump 2015 line
come on in and you know who came in
terrorists
convicts terrorists who's that
murderers and rapists and if we think
the border crisis is just a crisis at
the border we're gravely mistaken
uh really really crazy stuff and then
last one for you
mike pillow was at the event pillow was
interviewed he's still going on about
machines guys it's beyond belief uh we
have the bombshell evidence there's only
one machine in the united states now
where we have what you open up and there
it all is and that was uh tina peters
took her back or took off a copy of you
know backed up her computer that machine
is my espresso maker you open it up all
the evidence from the 2020 election i've
got it stuffed in there along with with
old coffee grounds
last summer when i had my symposium she
was there from that time on at least
eight different cyber
cyber cyber experts cyber experts did a
seven month investigation and yeah a
completely delusional guy and remember
that he is suing all machines we're
doing a class action lawsuit against all
machines
yeah i actually i i i'm waiting to find
out whether my bicycle is technically a
machine and if so it's going into the
witness protection program completely
insane completely insane we'll have
these clips on our instagram make sure
you're following us there at david
pakman show
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies mugs and
t-shirts you can support the show for as
little as two dollars a month check it
out at patreon.com david pakman show
today we're going to be speaking with a
republican congressional candidate named
darlene swaffer and i think this is
going to be very very interesting for
our audience darlene is a small business
owner and is running for congress in
florida's 22nd district uh darlene i
really appreciate you coming on today
thank you david thank you for having me
yeah and it's you know i'm always
interested in learning more about
different candidates their ideas whether
there might be you know my audience is
on the left and it's always interesting
to see where there might be
opportunities to sort of bridge divides
and work together and all of these
different types of things so let's kind
of contextualize your candidacy a little
bit
if i understand correctly
michael flynn and roger stone have both
endorsed you is that correct
that's correct and a few hours before
our interview you posted a picture of
yourself with the with the former
president donald trump and and you said
it was wonderful to meet my president
just as a sort of like gut check right
who's the current president of the
united states
uh i don't know that's debatable some
people feel that we had a stolen little
election and that's an illegitimate
president currently serving um you know
i have my own thoughts on that but
if you if you look back in the last
uh
one year and several months where are we
as a country i mean we went from being
energy independent to now
purchasing oil from russia and
negotiating oil with venezuela
we went from having very low inflation
to having very high inflation uh we got
back into the paris accord even though
we are very responsibly
um
uh a global citizen on our energy um
consumption well let's get to that but
darlene i want to hold you to who's the
current president
well
i don't believe that uh the current
president is a legitimate president and
we'll leave it at that is joe biden
currently the president even if you
think he's illegitimate is he the
president
i don't believe he is i don't believe
that is the current legitimate president
and who is the current legitimate
president
um
i don't i don't believe we have a
current legitimate president wow so in a
sense there's no president of the u.s
right now
i guess that's your interpretation of
what i said but okay
will you tell me i mean is there a
president right now i guess
um
well i i'd rather not answer that how's
that because i kind of feel like you're
leading down an area of controversy
um that we don't have to go
okay interesting
um let's talk about the energy
independence thing just to pick one
thing and so this i think will give my
audience a lot of kind of insights into
your into your campaign
um
the
united states in 2020
which was donald trump's last year in
office produced as much oil as we used
and i think that's what you're signaling
when you talk about being energy
independent we we used a certain amount
of oil and we produced an amount that
matched that
and in 2021
the same thing happened we produced as
much oil as we used so can you tell me
on what basis you say that we are no
longer energy independent under joe
biden
well actually if you look at the graph
of how much oil we've purchased from
russia it's significantly more than what
we were producing for ourselves i mean
that graph was well published and i'm
happy to email that to you
but that is an inaccurate statement that
you just shared it doesn't matter how
much oil we consume we can either
produce our own oil
and build back our reserves which is
what president trump did
or deplete our oil reserves and start
purchasing oil from other countries
which is evident in the price of gas
today i mean it was under two dollars a
gallon a year and three months ago and
what are we at now four dollars five
dollars in some cases six or seven
dollars that is your evidence let's get
back to gas prices and i want to really
with you i love the clarity of the
conversation where let's let's agree to
first talk oil and then we'll talk gas
so
did you know that the u.s for decades
has purchased oil from foreign countries
so under trump even though we produced
as much oil as we used some of the oil
we produce we export and to make up for
that we import some oil and under both
trump and biden we imported oil from
russia did you know that
did you know that in the last 20 years
we had presidents in the united states
that did not focus on energy
independence and producing our own our
own oil and offshore those opportunities
to other countries did you know that
well but that's not an answer to my
question that is an answer because it's
not about the trump presidency what
trump did was create energy independence
to the point where we were exporting oil
okay that's not what happened in
previous uh presidential administrations
but you criticized joe biden for
importing oil from russia obama
administration elisa the clinton
administration and elijah the bush
administration it was both democrat and
republican presidents that did not look
out for the interest of american
families and what trump did was put
american families first we have the
capability to farm our own uh reserves
from
gas coal and gas but darlene if we can
if we can darlene i really want to take
it one issue at a time i want to take it
one issue at a time
will you concede
that in both 2020 and 2021 u.s oil
production exceeded consumption will you
concede that and then we'll get to the
disagreement will you concede that
actually it's not a concession we did
produce more
oil than we consumed but that's because
we were able to export it and actually
earn income
back to the treasury on what we exported
now we're no longer in an exportation
phase we are purchasing oil from other
countries because we're not producing
enough oil let's see i don't want to
belabor it but at the same time i want
to make sure my audience understands
where where we're disagreeing in both
2020 and 2021 let's see if we can even
break it down more simply darlene in
2020 the u.s used a certain amount of
oil will you will you agree that we used
oil in 2020
of course okay we use oil will you agree
we used oil in 2021
we did use oil in 2021 good
will you agree
that in both 2020 and 2021 forget for a
second about exports we produced more
oil than we used in 2020 and 2021. are
we okay on that
right but but hold on just let's uh
we'll get to it we'll get to it but we
agree so far right right okay
in both 2020 and 2021 we exported some
oil
right yes and in 2020 and 2021 we
imported some oil from russia
we imported very little oil i don't have
the chart in front of me but we did
import some right right and we had to we
had to produce more oil because our oil
reserves were depleted under the obama
administration trump put back our oil
reserves during his administration would
you agree to that no i don't agree to
that but let's but let's get to that
we'll get to the disagreement so so far
this is great because we're really going
through the nuts and bolts we both agree
that in 2020 and 2021 the u.s produced
more oil than we used and we agreed that
in 2020 and 2021 we exported some oil
and we agree that in 20 and 21 we
imported some oil from russia so what's
the big criticism of what biden did in
21 it sounds like it was exactly the
same thing
well actually
we didn't purchase oil to the extent in
2021 like we did in 2020 or 2019 oh so
biden was more independent he didn't
purchase his money
purchased oil in 2021 that we did not as
a country purchase in 2020 2019 2018 and
2017. oh he purchased more years four
years under trump's administration we
did not purchase the oil from russia to
the extent of what biden has done got it
2021 okay that is fact okay all right
let's talk a little about gas prices
who's responsible for high global gas
prices right now
who's responsible for high global gas
prices if we are producing our own oil
we can control the market behind the
prices
that's economics 101 okay
but so right now would you agree that
gas prices are high in the united states
they are extremely high my brother is a
truck driver with his own rig okay it
cost over a thousand dollars to fill his
truck with gas okay what does that
equate to
he's going to have a higher cost for
logistics for to transport goods got it
that's going to translate to higher
prices of cost of goods sold absolutely
higher prices of retail
prices and then if you're purchasing
something that costs more today than it
did yesterday then you're paying higher
sales tax for it absolutely at the end
of the day we are all paying for
more
on based on the decisions of the current
administration let's but let's let's
wait so
we agree gas prices are high in the u.s
do you agree gas prices are high in
france right now
well france doesn't produce their own
oil but that wasn't my question darlene
is do you agree that gas prices are high
in france right now they're not
producing oil they're at the mercy of
supply and demand of countries they can
purchase oil from fine
but my question is do you agree gas
prices are high in france right now
they're high everywhere all over the
world
beautiful so we can even skip that part
okay
is joe biden responsible for that
absolutely 100 how why did he stop
production of the keystone pipeline why
are we not producing the same level of
oil that we did during the trump
administration
on why we can't produce our own oil hold
on a second though darlene let's take it
a step at a time now because we want to
be clear keystone xl pipeline you know
that keystone xl phase four well i guess
let's back up keystone xl is four phases
right three of the phases have been up
and running for years the fourth is what
we're now talking about agree so far
right so that was ten thousand jobs but
hold on a second hold on a second wait a
sec darlene wait a second okay
do you agree that phase four of keystone
xl was not active when trump was
president trump was trump wanted to do
construction but it wasn't active no of
course they weren't producing oil we're
not flowing the oil through that
pipeline beautiful agreed 100
do you agree that the pipeline is a
method of transporting oil not producing
it
that is a method of transporting oil but
that also reduces the cost of supply and
demand as well so you have to factor
that in what do you mean how if they can
get the oil to certain uh markets within
the united states more efficiently
that's going to reduce the cost
of production okay and transporting
correct your economics 101 is a big
thing for you right we're okay
do you know
how much
global oil production would go up if
keystone xl phase 4 was completed
how much it would go up in what respect
give an example percentage-wise so if
right now we are what we would call 100
right now the status quo is 100 percent
right if keystone xl phase 4 goes live
how much does oil production globally go
up
i don't have the answer to that it's one
percent why would you
why
i don't know if
that's your fact and i don't think that
fact is accurate no facts are facts
facts are not opinions a fact is a fact
it would go up one percent show me the
evidence behind that fact because i have
not heard that it would only be one
percent i actually think that's
radical liberal facts and people assume
that those are facts so share with us
what is your fact behind it's only being
one percent so
everybody from
everybody from the
nrdc
okay to
i mean it's you know
whoever you want to cite we're talking
about a one percent increase globally
that won't make a gas price difference
you know that darlene economics 101 and
actually i don't believe in that one
percent i believe that's the narrative
that they probably want everyone to kind
of run with okay so i i find it hard to
believe that a pipeline would only
produce one percent of the world
pipelines don't actually produce
anything they're just transport methods
it would allow the transport of one
percent more oil right you just don't
believe it
well share share the facts with your
audience share with me and then we can
analyze it how's that beautiful
beautiful okay
um
what do you think the top tax rate
should be
the top tax rate i actually
i believe as citizens were
double triple and quadruple taxed okay
so
uh i think right now the federal the
federal
tax
is um
in the 33 percentile when you add
everything together what do you mean
percentile
well when you're looking at how you do
your taxes right yep
it's around 30 plus percent that comes
out of your income in terms of taxes
state
uh federal county any local taxes when
you add all that up together well it
depends what state you live in how much
you make and a lot of things right
correct i was an accounting and finance
major i did my taxes for many years so
it's around that that bracket
um so you add medicare tax you add the
med you know the all the different taxes
about that much and then on top of that
you have sales tax and then on top of
that you have gas tax and then you know
if you smoke there's a cigarette tax um
and then you know when you die yeah
there's taxes everything there's taxes
on everything okay so and then when you
die there's an estate tax it's 35 if you
have more than 10 and a half million
dollars
no actually it's less than that no it's
10 and a half million yeah
yeah no it's less than that what do you
think it is
well there's a death tax of three like
if i if i die tomorrow
uh before my son could collect any
assets yep there's a death tax did you
know that that starts at 11 that starts
at 11 your first 11 million dollars
there's no federal estate tax
there's a death tax no
yes where'd you get that
um
there's a death tax
that everybody goes through when you die
and you leave your assets to your heirs
right that's the tax that is going to be
assessed
by the government before your heirs get
any money but this is one of the big
this is wild darlene you're a candidate
and it sounds like you don't know that
the first 11.7 million dollars of one's
estate
doesn't you won't you only pay tax after
you leave 11.7 million to your heirs you
didn't know that did you
if it's 11.7
how is it that my because i deal with
seniors all day long from the medicare
lady okay okay and i had it i had a
client that only had
250 000
and her estate was hit with a death tax
before her children collected it so how
did that happen with her maybe it was at
the state level i don't know but
federally there's an 11.7 million but
hold on but hold on there's a you can
your first 11.7 million
there's no tax federally
right on the federal level okay but you
didn't know that two minutes ago right
right but that's on the federal level
there so my i deal with seniors all day
long that's what i do for the last 11
years and i've heard way too many as a
matter of fact this is the biggest
concern that seniors have brought to my
attention
that they have to set up a trust which
cost three thousand dollars typically to
set up about twenty five hundred to
three thousand yeah so that they could
try to protect their assets and not be
subject to that death tax before they
leave their children any money now
wouldn't that be the right thing to do
as someone advising seniors to let them
know that their first 11.7 million are
exempt
well i'm not a tax advisor so that's not
up to me legally to share that
information with them i sell medicare
health insurance so i'm not going to
give advice fair um that has nothing to
do with my life i think that's
responsible darlene um okay darlene
listen this has been incredibly
illuminating and i can't thank you
enough i think we've had
a number of disagreements you had the
one very interesting idea there about
not non-taxable overtime hours very very
interesting i can't tell you how much i
appreciate you spending some time with
us today
thank you i appreciate that too and i'd
love to see the facts behind what you
shared one percent how that's going to
add to the oil supply i know that's
inaccurate but we'd love to see the data
on that when we publish this maybe your
sources are inaccurate and you don't
know so i'm gonna look into it too and
whatever i find i'm gonna send it to you
please darlene it's been an unfettered
pleasure on our end
all right thank you thank you so much
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
all right after that wacky trumpist
interlude with darlene swaffer let's get
into the last component of this
dystopian rally over the weekend the
attendees the people who went to the
trump rally because remember without
followers the movement is nothing here
is a woman who started crying she
started crying because she misses trump
so much this country trump loves this
country i love my country
we need to straighten this country up i
have children and we need
we need you trump
our country is going
yeah i agree with you i'm gonna give you
a hug
this is why this is why we do this with
people like you because we know how
important it is for we know we love this
country we know exactly
this is more sad than anything else i
mean you know crying because trump was
president makes more sense like crying
because it's it was such a terrible
a terrible episode in this country says
like that would make sense you know it
was horrible it was absolutely
humiliating globally
crying because you want the guy back so
bad that is just very very strange then
they interviewed another woman
who said she's planning to cry when
trump comes out on stage so what's your
anticipation for today i mean you've got
thousands of people here you've got mike
lindell behind us he's going to walk out
on that on that platform it's just going
to be exciting
it's i i will probably cry when i see
him and everybody else this is very
emotional because we're finally people
are finally waking up to what happened
in 2020
it's very emotional
you're the same thing it's a very
emotional experience when he walks
around the stage it is i was in
washington d.c
and that was amazing on which day on
january 6th for the election
that was millions what a great day that
was that was an amazing day
this is a cult leader guys this i it's
it's sounding more and more like the
cultists you read about when you read
about charles manson when you read about
the people's temple uh the same woman
was asked why she likes trump listen to
what she says it's the opposite of
what's true why do you love president
trump
well he's honest he's the biggest liar
in the history of american presidents
undeniable fact he's a christian he's
obviously not a christian he doesn't
know anything about the bible he didn't
go to church he concocted that to trick
people like this woman and it worked
that's why he did it because it worked
the proof is in the pudding this woman
believed it his um anti-abortion
he's not anti-abortion he was in favor
of choice until he was 68. he decided to
run and said i got to come up with some
story about why i'm against abortion and
he came up with i met a kid i liked and
the mom told me she once thought about
an abortion and from that day forward i
was a and that happened when he was 68.
they've fallen for all of it
and he calls it like it is he says what
all of us are thinking if we're all
thinking the things trump says we're
screwed we're really screwed then they
spoke to some guy who's running for
school board on an anti-critical race
theory platform
no crt right no crt
matter of fact one plus one is two if
you have two x chromosomes you are a
what
female yes come on people biology one on
one the funniest part is
this is not the crowd that knows about
biology you know that if it
i don't want to belabor that but if
you're trying to ask chromosomal or
genetic questions
the people waiting to go to the trump
rally i'm sorry guys are not exactly the
people that you ask um okay then uh i
can't do too too much of this but um
let's go to
a woman who also explained i guess why
she loves trump say about it you love
your trump absolutely number one reason
why you love president trump is why he's
gonna save america and he loves us
he absolutely loves us you know what's
really funny and sad about that
one of the things we've learned is trump
doesn't love these people trump's
followers are the people he spent his
life trying to stay away from
and if they are useful to him voting
wise he'll pretend to like them and if
they're useful donor wise he'll pretend
to like them but then he'll abandon them
he'll screw them he'll scam them and you
know what if he runs in 24 he'll pretend
to like them again but they've fallen
for all of it last one listen this one
you can't even come up with an
introduction to this one donald trump
you know he's the modern day muhammad
ali you know yes sir yes something like
a b he's gonna hit harder next time
right here the only similarity i can
think of between trump and muhammad ali
is both figured out ways not to go to
vietnam albeit for very different
reasons muhammad ali because he was an
objector
and trump because
he was i guess scared and claimed to
have bone spurs so that that's that's
the only thing i can think of uh very
scary stuff these people vote which
means we have to vote sarah palin is
running for congress sarah palin is the
for our younger viewers she was a sort
of precursor to the trump types this is
this is actually a really interesting
political history moment
bush george w bush was kind of dim
and uh
the thing about him is he's not really
all of it led to trump but he's not
really the pre-trump mold in the sense
that he was actually a neocon bush was a
neocon
palin was kind of the first what i call
sort of like uh
dumacon where it's like you're the main
thing is you don't know anything with
bush he didn't know much but he was
still a neocon at heart
palin was the first sliver of what
eventually was trump and trumpism which
is they're just clueless reactionaries
lacking any real ideology and she was
the late john mccain's running mate in
2008 they fortunately lost to barack
obama and she is now running for
congress sarah palin files to run for
the late alaska representative don
young's seat
sarah palin filed with the fec on friday
for the special election she said
america is at a tipping point as i've
watched the far left destroy the country
i knew i had to step up and join the
fight
palin filed an hour before friday's
filing let deadline there are 50
candidates in the field so for the we'll
have plenty of time to talk about sarah
palin more but for those who maybe don't
remember her
she was known for the word salad before
trump perfected it here's one example
from an interview in 2016 with jake
tapper uh a visibly disoriented sarah
palin here
you talked about inconsistencies among
the votes and the positions of senator
cruz donald trump is somebody who has
clearly had uh different positions on
issues that he has today including an
issue very near and dear to your heart
the issue of abortion and life right uh
have you talked to him about that he
used to be he called himself very
pro-choice now he says he's very
pro-life i am so glad that mr trump has
seen the light and understands the the
sanctity of innocent life and how um a
baby in the womb it should be most
protected what has been kind of sad
about the situation though politically
speaking are groups that are pro-life
and want to they say they want to bring
more people into the fold they given
trump a hard time for his past views on
abortion where they're celebrating
others like um i was going through a
list
like justin bieber
what
and um
gosh
yeah yeah who who has made
that that this is jake tapper's best
moment where he looks perplexed and goes
justin bieber
yeah we i don't know either uh jake it's
understanding the the sanctity of life
but in the past he said he was no big
deal to him you know
he's just one example but i've heard
these same groups celebrate people who
have i've been to their fundraisers i've
spoken at their events and there's
usually someone in the crowd every
single one of these crowds who'll
testify to having seen the light you
know to understand oh i yeah so i'm
really hoping that she does some debates
uh here's one more example again for our
young viewers
here is sarah palin speaking at a trump
event and really just
an incredible word salad immigrants
welcoming this is like a chop chop
they've really chopped it all up and
it's just like confetti them in even
inducing and seducing them with gift
baskets come on over the border and
here's a gift basket of teddy bears and
soccer balls our kids and our grandkids
they'll never know then
what it is to be rewarded for that
entrepreneurial spirit that god creates
within us
in order to work and to produce and to
strive and to thrive and to really be
alive
wisconsin
reagan saved the hog
here
you're harley davidson that was reagan
it made as little sense then as it does
now and we can only hope that sarah
palin will be participating in debates
so sarah palin is running another
notable race in 2020 much ahead when it
comes to the midterms we have a
voicemail number and that number is 2192
david p
the san antonio troll is known for one
thing on this show for nearly a decade
he calls in and criticizes me for things
i have never said a particularly manic
troll from san antonio called in unable
to control himself still criticizing me
for things i certainly never said
oh sorry let's take it from the top
uh pac-man i'm just wondering do you
ever do a video oh something
i mean i don't know i've never said
trump's on the verge of death i don't
even know what this is in reference to
coughs are sniffles
you know you've done this about
everywhere not like when none of them
has died i think hurricane is the only
one that died we look older on the verge
of death they're about to die
well
when it's been reported that people are
actually on the verge of death like the
many radio hosts who were you know in a
in a medically induced coma for weeks
and it was reported they are on the
verge of death we would we would but do
i would report that but do you
understand that that's not my language
that's from other media outlets
but other than that as usual the san
antonio troll furious with me for things
i never said
how does it feel even wrong just so
consistently and i'll tell you something
you
i mean
you you go on to say that desantis is
mismanaged covenant worse than any other
government you don't even mention andrew
cuomo in fact just saying andrew
coleman's name you already hung the call
up and uh
actually i've criticized cuomo
extensively
uh again
we i don't care about party i don't care
about democrats i don't care about
republicans desantis mismanaged covid
cuomo mismanaged covid in different ways
we've talked about it all san antonio
troll either criticized me for things
i've said or call whoever is saying this
stuff because it certainly is not me we
have a fantastic bonus show for you
today get instant access by becoming a
member at joinpacman.com
you